why I'm curious why as a as a woman who
works at the United Nations why you
would even want to have a spectre of
doubt about it I've read so many because
of the beheaded babies because of the
claim of beheaded babies how many
journalists sorry Pierce including
yourself have Amplified this news of the
and use this argument of the beheaded
babies what do you think are you
predicting unbelievable that he's saying
that it is it is because you know you've
been there bro keep lying about this
stuff by the grace of Allah subhah wa
ta'ala the response has been
overwhelming to say the very least
alhamdulillah we've had social media
personalities and respected Scholars
from many parts of the Muslim world
promoting the cause we have raised
almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah and we
haven't been sitting ideally waiting to
hit our Target of 2 million we have
fully purchased 4 properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
taala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in today
we're going to be reacting to um P
Morgan who's obviously nothing needs to
be said I mean the people who' have been
on there including yourself as done an
amazing job but here is a un official FR
Franchesca Al ales albanes she's on
there and she calls him out on the whole
40 beheaded baby things yeah okay so
this how it goes are you guys ready yeah
people say it it did happen now the
point is no said no the UN no no the
Comm the UN is a is a there are
political appointees and then human
rights appointees and uh and the
commission of inquiry concluded that
there was no in
that there was no evidence to support
the claims of gang rape but let's assume
I I don't want to say anything that I've
not investigated so let's assume that
rape occurred so does it justify what
Israel has done what the the reason why
why I'm curious why as a as a woman who
works at the United Nations why you
would even want to have a spectre of
doubt about it I've read so many because
of the beheaded babies because of the
claim of beheaded babies how many
journalists sorry here including
yourself have Amplified this news of the
and used this argument of the beheaded
babies what do you think I said uh well
you have you have refer you have you
have asked the people do you condemn
Hamas and you have mentioned the
beheaded babies what do you think I said
what do you mean what I think you said
quote back to me what you think I said
about babies beheaded babies yeah did
you say that or not all I've seen ever
since I'm about to answer you all I've
seen ever since is that I apparently
said that up to 40 babies have being
beheaded I never said that I choked up
earlier reading this new revelation
about 40 babies being killed oh my God
and some of them being beheaded and I
was like how How can any human being do
that to a baby I don't know I it's
completely untrue you said no no no I
look you have said you have referred to
I don't know if 40 you have referred to
the beheaded babies or to the babies
about babies being killed people being
beheaded which they were because you
know how we know that is Hamas broadcast
it on their GoPro cameras so there you
go you can see very clearly and this is
the reason why that's actually
unbelievable that he's saying that it is
it is because you know you've been there
bro why does he keep lying about this
stuff about this point in particular cuz
I think bessam YF in his first interview
he said the same thing he said that you
said about the be of babies and he came
back and said well I didn't say that and
I think the the phraseology he used
maybe in another clip was decapitated
babies which is a synonym by the way
okay so I mean we've just seen in the
other clip that he did use the term
beheaded babies and he did clearly imply
that they there was beheading and that
that happened on GoPro was broadcasted
on bro uh GoPro cameras by Hamas where
they were gleefully doing it that's not
true that's not true cuz I haven't seen
that footage what on about I haven't
seen that footage and and the thing is
interesting is like you have to prepare
for these debates because you can see
what the lady was saying is sh but he
kind of CAU out well quote me then quote
me then and and we went back to that
clip and it's very clear no no no no no
the thing is she's a human rights expert
yeah Italian human rights expert she's a
un special repertoire and she was one of
the early ones to put her neck on the
line and say this is a plausible
genocide that's her field those are the
sorts of questions you should be asking
this exact word fallacy PE knows exactly
what he's doing he's taking her out of
her comfort zone because you could see
she was on a role and then he's where
did I say this where did I her response
was good did you not say this and then
now when he said no now we can um do the
homework and we can obviously present
those clips however he knew exactly what
he's doing because if he then questions
the fact that it's a genocide or if he
questions um what the UN has said or
done obviously she knows and that's her
field but PE is going to be very snidey
and snaky here and Andrew in any court
of law yeah I think it was it was you're
right I think it was the strategy of
debate exactly exactly and you know know
we involved in debates so the thing is
this that is that in in a court of law
if I as a witness make a statement and
it is a lie then you know that my my
credibility is in question here yeah so
very clearly and and andon he actually
has to retract of course not only that
when it comes to apologize when it comes
to the whole grape issue that they're
this woman exactly but what about the
whole issue where she said he he was
even questioning her Womanhood yeah yeah
know exactly as a woman how could you
what do you mean it's not and she said
rightly so because of the 40 babies that
wasn't true how am I supposed to believe
this whole great thing as well so you
can clearly see I mean we know what P
Morgan's about you know but you can see
the tactics that they're using and if
this was in any case if if if this was
the same question asked to him about
Ukraine bro the answer would be
compl completely different they're doing
a gen they're wrong with the m Hassan
interview he was very categorical on the
one hand he was saying yeah yeah yeah I
know all of this all of this is a fact I
don't need to see anything but when it
comes to this what was it Moral Moral
quandry yeah ah
ah wow he's in a moral conjur I haven't
heard that word he's been a moral for
quite a long time hasn't he he has yes
Subhan Allah
exactly I mean any last words guys no I
think with this he has to actually come
with an apology he's not but this gu if
he doesn't come out with an apology then
his credibility is I mean has no
credibility it's true but with something
like this where you you can prove it
it's objectively false it's not a matter
of opinion here this is not a matter of
opinion exactly if he doesn't do it then
I'm sorry to say I think I think he
needs to retire and his wife needs to
divorce him does he have a wife or a
husband whoever yeah no he's not
homosexual I don't think so no no no not
he has a right to be if he wants
to if he wants to I'm just saying that
yeah the yeah I mean it should there's
nothing wrong with he can be homosexual
if he wants to to in this Society he can
be yes yeah let him be a homosexual if
he wants to I mean I'm not stopping him
why why wife why can't you have a
boyfriend that's or a man that's
dominating why can he not probably
someone is no you're not it's it's I
think in his worldview he he has a right
to be dominated if he wants to I think
ruper Mok his boss is probably
dominating him when the camera switch
off I think that's it maybe maybe he's
in a dominant country we don't
know anyways are you are you
projecting anyways uh to our next time
guys with uh what does quandry mean
confusion is it blood why those big
words confusion yes he's def no to
defend Israel you have to go to the
thesaurus no it's just cuz cuz when you
mentioned conjury I got a conjury does
that make sense confused does that make
sense no okay it's not working till next
time